[Thumping on roof]
- [Jimmy Garoppolo:] Another great drive, babes.
Kittle, babe, you GOTTA condition that long hair.
We got enough split ends.
- Hello!
- Whoa, whoa, not again!
- Oh, no. What's this?
I killed Jimmy Garoppolo.
- Nah, that would be too dark for a kids program.
See you in the postseason, Brick.
- Woo, it's a physical sport. Next man up.
- CMC drives sleigh.
This Santa Clause seems like it's on very shaky legal ground, no?
- You're in charge of distributing the footballs now.
- Forever?
- We don't like to think about next year here in Santa's Clara.
- Deebo will help you with anything you need.
- Oh, great. More things for me to do.
- And this is Bosa, our Sackmaster.
- Haha, sack.
- My cheekbones are more photogenic.
And my voice is deeper? Oh no, is this a horror story?
- Look, it happens all the time. See?
- Guess I gotta buy some shoes to fill.
- Oh, boy. This is a rough game.
- Don't mind if I f--kin' do.
- Flac-ho ho ho! Look who's came crawling back?
- I didn't even get hurt!
- Keep an eye on the internal clock on the sleigh.
You have three seconds to deliver each ball.
- Hut, hut.
- Nothing over five yards, OK, Brock?
- Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell Brock.
Jingle around the-
-Hey.
- He does exist.